hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast advanced analysis of complex
fill models with the new operetta CLS
high content analysis system
I'm Christina Joel of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event we
are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
rooms and sponsored by PerkinElmer
PerkinElmer is a global leader focused
on improving the health and safety of
people and the environment their
innovative detection imaging informatics
and service capabilities combined with
deep market knowledge and expertise
health customers gain greater insights
into their science before we begin just
a couple of important announcements this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button on the lower left I would now
like to introduce today's speakers we
have two speakers today Jacobs high
store and Joe Trask speaking first today
will be dr. Jacob tester at portfolio
director for high content instruments
dr. Chester leads global product
management and application development
for high content screening at
PerkinElmer he holds a doctorate in
biochemistry from Hanover University and
in research on nuclear hormone receptors
at the Max Planck Institute dr. tester
has held several imaging related sales
and marketing world across proteomics
micro a micro arrays preclinical imaging
and high content analysis and joined
PerkinElmer in 2010 I will now hand over
to dr. tester for his presentation dr.
tensor
thank you Christina thank you Christina
good afternoon good morning everybody
and I would like to present you our new
operetta CLS high content analysis
system and I would like to start this
presentation with a little introduction
as to why we would want to do high
content screening drug development is
still one of the most expensive efforts
in our industry costing up to 10 years
worth of research in 2.6 billion dollars
to bring a drug to market only 12% of
all candidates that enter phase one pass
this critical clinical phase and this
adds to the cost of drug development how
can we improve that how can we as
PerkinElmer help you to improve this
process recently the paper was published
by Jax canal in bosley where they
positioned that quality can be the
quantity and they did a mathematical
modeling of the drug discovery process
to understand how the quality of the pro
models you're using for your research
impact your chances of finding good drug
candidates this graph from this paper
basically shows the relationship between
the correlation of your model predictive
value and the throughput that you
achieve and your chances of success in
this process what this graph tells you
is that even small changes in the value
of your in the value of the correlation
between your model and the clinical
approval improve greatly the chances of
finding good drugs how can we help you
to improve the productivity of your
model system this is really what the
development of high content screening
and PerkinElmer is about can we help you
I hope yes
one thing that has happened over time
was really the improvement of model
systems used for high content screening
used for drug discovery many years back
people were using simple cell lines like
HeLa and we're looking for simple
effects like translocations or simple
stains as shown here in this little
image in the past couple of years a
large number of much more powerful and
much more plug physiologically relevant
models have come up some examples are
shown here this is an example of using
primary red ganglion cells this is an
example of coca stem cell co-cultures
and this is IPSC derived cardiomyocytes
all used as model systems for drug
discovery and primary research they are
much closer to the situation the human
body than the HeLa cells ever were
increasingly we see even higher value
models coming up were you seeing more
and more people working with live cells
we're seeing model organisms like
zebrafish gaining in importance we see a
tremendous increase in working with
spheroids and organoids which is
three-dimensional model systems
providing a much richer environment for
the cells to differentiate in ways that
resemble the human body and we shall see
also been increased work with tissue
slides we see also more advanced models
using for example threat to look at
protein protein interaction all these
new model systems mean that you need
more imaging power once working with
primary cells the phenotype you're
looking for becomes more scarce when
working with co-cultures only part of
the cells will be the cells of interest
in your image when working with
spheroids you will want to sample
throughout multiple planes to get a good
representation of the total spheroid all
these means that the demands for an
high-content instrument are ever
increasing both
in terms of throughput image quality and
analysis capabilities and this is where
we try to help with our new operetta CLS
PerkinElmer has been involved in high
content screening for over a decade now
the first instrument we brought to
market was the then leading opera a high
content screening system was the first
multi camera laser based spinning disk
confocal system and at that time had a
really innovative powerful a capella
image analysis software but that
software was the next per tool it was
not most intuitive but took quite a lot
of learning time to get acquainted with
it we took the experience with the Opera
and we brought the operetta high score
ican't an analysis system which was a
land-based simple desktop unit with
combined confocal imaging was it really
easy to use harmony software suite which
was hiding the power of a capella
underneath and easier user interface we
developed this software further so that
it could deal with more complex assays
and we succeeded the old opera with the
upper of Phoenix in 2014 here we brought
together a laser based micro lens can
focal system that could hold one to four
cameras but being operated by really
easy-to-use software and now in 2016
were bringing to you the operetta CLS
here we combine the fast mechanics from
the opera phoenix with an LED based
single camera system providing an
extremely powerful imaging device aimed
at the middle range of the market at the
same time we have always increase our
image analysis and data analysis
capabilities which are inherently
important for high content screening was
Columbus and the TIBCO Spotfire HD
profiler so
operetta CLS we see it as a truly unique
combination of technologies which
enables you to do sensitive imaging to
run your everyday Ana analysis everyday
the right way to ultimately reveal deep
biological insights what I'm going to
talk to you about now there's a lot of
the technical detail of this instrument
and then in the second part of this
webinar we will hear more of the actual
application to use of these features
when we talk about imaging it's all
about managing lights bringing light to
the sample and even more importantly
collecting light from the sample and
delivering it in a very efficient way to
the detector when we design the operetta
CLS we looked at every single step of
this process and try to improve the
performance of the old operetta all the
way during this talk I'm going to talk a
little bit more about the light source
which we now use a high power LED source
which is directly coupled into the light
pass we're going to talk a little bit
about the spinning disk confocal and
what that delivers to the type of
application that we're talking about and
we're talking about the objective lenses
which play a crucial role blows in
delivering light and collecting light
from the sample we also have an eighth
position dichroic wheel which allows you
to combine the excitation wavelengths
and select the emission wavelengths
ideally matched to every single LED we
have a matching emission filter wheel
which is user accessible so that you can
choose the right filters for your essays
and we have a lot format
state-of-the-art a CMOS camera that
captures large high dynamic range low
noise images in the past we stayed with
lamp excitation for quite a while
because we still felt it gave you very
good power and very good excitation
efficiency but LED
have developed very rapidly over the
last couple of years and we felt now
there was a good time to combine the
best tech LEDs we could find into one
very compact very high power internal
LED light source this allows us to
provide light with direct injection
without any fire burst to the sample and
switch those between different light at
wavelengths quickly without slowing down
the process it also means that we have
the very same path lengths for all
wavelengths and it makes as a very
stable illumination source you can
choose from a four LED set or neg LED
set depending on the number of
fluorophores and type of lower flows you
want to use so this light source is
internal to the instrument and supports
a broad range of fluorophores we need a
lot of light we need a high excitation
energy to also enable true multi-point
control called scanning the benefit of
confocal scanning is clearly to reduce
background noise and background blurring
it also improves the resolution in XY
and Z as you can see on these two images
the left-hand image is a white fill
image acquired on operetta CLS the
right-hand image is the good focal image
that matches the sample and if you look
carefully you can see the improved
resolution bows on the actin fibers and
also on the antibody staying here
what you will understand is that
introducing a confocal disc reduces that
know the amount of excitation light
dramatically therefore we have to have a
lot of excitation light entering the
light pause and this is what we achieve
with our new light source more
importantly is how do we collect light
from the sample and here we introduce
for the first time in a system in this
performance range or
objectives this is a propriety tone
proprietary technology to PerkinElmer
which we have first introduced in the
upper room which allows us to operate
water immersion objectives in true
screening conditions and to visualize
the effect of a water immersion
objective we took the same image was the
same exposure setting same exposure time
same exposures power and also the same
contrast settings for display one time
with a very nice 40 X 0.7 a air lens and
now we took the very same image where's
the corresponding water immersion
objective as you will see this image is
much brighter actually four times much
brighter and it also provides better
resolution this is very beautiful and it
also gives you the limits of what is
possible with high content screening
today in terms of resolution and cell in
a detail but it might not be
quantitative enough for your time taste
the next slide we try to put a more
quantitative view on how different
objectives on the operetta CLS compare
in this experiment we took the 60 plane
confocal Zed stack of a stacked have g2
culture so if you look left hand side
you will see one plane out of this stack
and you will see up here the exit view
and to the left you will see the stack
and why is that view what you can see
immediately and this stack has been
acquired with a 40 X long working
distant objective was an na of 0.6 that
the image is somewhat blurry and that it
is clearly distorted in that direction
it took us
34 seconds to acquire the stack of sixty
planes we had to excite a very high
power for a significant amount of time
and when we compared one plane before
and after acquiring the stack actually
the signal was 27 percent lower so the
significant amount of bleaching had
occurred when we move to a higher na
objective we can reduce the excitation
energy so time exposure time times power
setting significantly to maybe thirty
percent of what we use before we will
reduce the bleaching and the time to
require the stack becomes significantly
shorter so this is possible with an air
objective if we move to the very right
of the slide you will see the result as
it looks when acquired with a water
immersion objective please note that if
you watch the X that view here and the
Y's that view here that nuclei are much
better resolved in zet when compared to
either the high na or the long working
distance objective also you can see that
the degree of control cavity is much
better much more of the higher plane
blur has been rejected from the image
more importantly though exposure times
could be further reduced so we're only
providing one tenth of the energy the
sec acquisition is more than four times
faster than with the long working
distance objective and bleaching has
been reduced to minimum now you might
say this is just an Hookes limit and
might be rather boring example of that
but bleaching of hook's is a really good
proxy to understand what is a citation
power might do to your life cell samples
or less bleaching you have an experiment
like this
better live cells will tolerate long
term extended time lapse energy so
managing excitation light is a key
consideration when planning for
long-term lifestyle experiments so this
should give you an idea how much water
immersion objectives can speed up your
research and can improve your research
results this is pretty much what I
wanted to talk to you about regarding
the hardware of the apparatus Els we
have a very fast system that will
capture up to 100,000 wells in a single
color assay or up to 50,000 Wells in a
four color essay during a single day
running extremely accurate and extremely
fast mechanics throughout the whole
process having very powerful excitation
light sources having very efficient
light collection optics and providing a
lot of images in a very short amount of
time
all of this controlled by very
easy-to-use software which we call
harmony I'm a strong believer that
usability of high content devices is key
in achieving good usability and good use
out of your investment this is why we
continuously invest in improving harmony
to provide you access to all the power
of the hardware and to enable advanced
experiments with operetta CLS we bring a
new version of Harmony how many 4.5 and
we're gonna show case a few of the most
advanced features here for those of you
who don't know harmony this gives you
brief idea of how harmony looks it's a
workflow oriented interface it starts
with setting up your experiment running
your experiment
setting up your image analysis and
finally looking at the evaluation for
example
easy 50 curves you always set up your
experiment or your analysis on the left
hand side you see your results at the
glance at the lower bottom and and you
navigate through images and stacks on
the right side of the window
now let's discuss a few of the newest
features in harmony 4.5 most importantly
the plugin that we dubbed Pressy scan
would provide you with access to
intelligent image acquisition so what is
that very typically these days you
encounter some sort of rare event
screening where the phenotype of
interest is few and far in between
inside of given well imaging the whole
well at high resolution becomes
impractical because it would create a
huge amount of data in the surge of very
few cells that are really of interest
the same holds true for example for
micro tissues which may be located
anywhere in the well and where you want
to acquire a high-resolution stack so
the idea of Pressy scan is that in a
given well you do a low magnification
pre scan here for example at 5x you use
online image analysis to identify the
cells of interest and then you provide
those positions back to the software for
a subsequent rescan at a higher
magnification of your choice for example
at 63 X due to the high accuracy of our
stage and the automatic image alignment
we can do in our software this process
is extremely precise allowing you to go
from 5x to 63 X without missing a cell
basically I'm going to show you this on
a example we've done on a side-to-side
which you see here situ provides Micro
patterned plates micro pattern slides
and this is one example
these slides are covered with a pattern
which only allows cells to adhere to
these little triangular shapes that you
can see here on the left and typically
only one cell will adhere but what you
will do during seeding you will see
there certain number of cells and some
of these patterns will be covered by no
cell some patterns will be covered by
one cell and some few patterns will be
covered by two cells but to really
benefit from this patterning all you are
interested in are those patterns that
are actually covered by a single cell so
Pressey scan allows you to do pre-scan
at five x here on the left hand side run
an image analysis using all the building
blocks and harmony to identify exactly
those patterns that contain one cell and
only one cell and then direct the rescan
at 63 x to capture for example a stack
at those positions and as you will see
on the next slide this works actually
quite nicely so as a result of the
presses can routine what you get in this
case are 6 image stacks and here you see
a maximum intensity projection of 6
pattern each pattern occupied by a
single cell and what you will also see
is that the positioning is extremely
precise so this is a really useful tool
which opens up a whole range of new
applications to high content screening
on operettas Els another may be more
relevant example to many of you is shown
here this is a plate
provided to us by 0 which holds 3d
inside micro tissues in a gravity trap
plate and as you can see on the left
hand side
this is a pre scan at 10x you can see
that the micro tissue can be found all
in all different wells and in very
different locations if all you wanted to
do is a high-resolution scan of the
micro tissue this would become very
impractical so we use this priests can
we run an image analysis and then we do
the 20x rescan in this case and the
result as a montage window across the
whole plate is shown here and what you
will note is left hand well was an empty
well in the pre scan and no image was
acquired in the rescan maybe also
interesting because you were able to
configure the image analysis in a very
detailed way artifacts like here are not
recognized as tissue and therefore
result and no image in the rescan where
micro tissue was nicely centered like
here you can basically see that it is
very much centered in the 20x image as
well and this would have worked also for
a 40 X ray scan or a 60 X ray scan so
because you have access to all the image
analysis tools and harmony you can
tailor the image analysis that you do on
the priests can very accurately to only
pick up the cells of interest another
tool that we are introducing was harmony
4.5 is the global image this is actually
a stitching routine that allows you to
stitch and down sample the images
acquired at high resolution to create a
lower resolution overview of your well
for example as let's played here so this
is a long object image at five weeks
this is the same of
image 10x and this is the same object
image with lots of fields a 20x and we
can now basically assemble these
high-resolution images to give us a
lower resolution image to really
appreciate the large structure we use
this for example to analyze a stretch
1sa the data was kindly provided by
Brunel endings lab and the University of
Copenhagen Denmark and what you can see
here is the downsampled stitched image
which allows you to detect the bound as
shown in pink on the on the right hand
side here which is basically created
from the 25 high-resolution images
indicated in the lower left hand corner
now why would you want to do this is you
could do the top left hand corner image
easily with a 5x magnification but then
you would not be able to analyze cells
for subtle phenotypic changes whereas in
20x image you would be able to pick up
very subtle phenotypic changes and you
can then use harmony to basically
classify phenotypes in relation to their
position - for example the bottom
boundary this is a very useful tool for
a wide variety of different application
wound healing scratches is being shown
here but you could also use this to
characterize stem cell colonies really
Micro tissues for example to define what
is the core and what is the boundary of
the micro tissues or maybe even for
model organisms like zebrafish with this
I would like to end my part of the
presentation providing you with a final
overview of the Opera C operator CLS
which has one camera 48 high power LED
provides you with spinning disk confocal
t has a user accessible eighth position
emission
filter wheel and if you look at it for
color si is good for more than 50,000
Wells a day compared to the upper
Phoenix which features up to four
cameras is powered by lasers for
excitation synchrony optics to crosstalk
suppression during as a multi Gnaeus
acquisition and benefits from a micro
lens enhanced and in this control go
this one will give you even hundred
thousand well today for for caller si
those systems share really the same
camera type the same objective lenses
the same options for white field and
could focal imaging bright field and
digital face imaging and they share the
very same mechanics that enabled this
very fast image acquisition they have
six position objective turrets with
options for the temperature and sea and
to control we have the Harmony four
point five software which provides the
access to the features we've often just
been talking about all of this is
basically part of Perkin Alma's
integrated suite of high contents
cleaning solutions which should only
include the detection instruments we
were speaking about before but also
sample handling solutions imaging plates
really advanced image analysis tools
either in harmony or in our server based
Columbus a suite of things and then last
but not least was high quantum profiler
a dedicated tool for multi parametric
profiling and hit selection all of that
truly supported by our support teams
globally to enable you higher
productivity and hopefully fostering
better decisions from your data thank
you
Thank You dr. Chester
our next speaker is mr. Joe Trask Joe
join PerkinElmer in July 2016 and is
instrumental in strategic customer
support through teaching training and
collaborations he brings over 20 years
of experience in high content screening
technology in academia at Duke
University and Ohio State University in
the pharmaceutical industry at abbott
laboratories and eli lilly and company
and in biotechnology at the hammer
institute for health sciences and fight
ovation Joe has extensive experience in
cell based technologies from flow
cytometry confocal microscopy and
computer assisted automated microscopy
studying cancer immunology
neurodegeneration and hosta ecology here
you go Joe great Thank You Kristina for
that and I would thank you hiccup or the
introduction I think that's a great
segue into my discussion today which I'm
going to talk to you about some of the
applications that have been run on the
operetta cos imaging system so just as a
general in impression for me since I've
just joined PerkinElmer in July of 2016
is that my impression of the system was
fantastic this is a great imaging system
I was really impressed with the high
power LED light sources that Yukos is
mentioning about the hardware components
of the system so I'm not going to go
through those but I can tell you this is
offers a great offering for the
community I'm really impressed with the
harmony image analysis software and some
of the new tools that are available that
you just mentioned especially the global
image and Cressy scan which I'll be
giving some more application examples of
that
and I really want to just really start
up and talk a little bit more about the
3d imaging aspect of the CLS instrument
so when we start when we think about 3d
imaging and and so yeah I could pointed
out that you know these these models are
becoming more complex and we were the
reason for doing this is that we really
want to try to recapitulate the invivo
environments and when we challenge these
these cell models with compounded drugs
we're trying to try to mimic that in
vivo environment and doing that if 3d
models really are a good way to do this
and in a vitro plate so and when we
start to look at these spheroids for
example as a representation of a
three-dimensional measurement we will
capture this these stacks as we call
them so kit we get these individual
planes that you know that are shown here
and we can clip many of these at
different z-c heights as we call them
and these can be anywhere from a half a
micron to to several microns in size so
there's actually two ways to do
three-dimensional measurements we can
either take the stack we can actually
collapse we can collapse the stack and
this will form a maximal projection
intensity of the all the planes together
and this is a this is a way for us to do
a very fast measurement and this does
not take you know long long to do so the
maximal projection intensity collapse
images are much faster way to do
analysis of three-dimensional image
stacks the other method is to do
individual measurements on each point
and when we do this this in a relative
analysis this extra can increase the
analysis time by several fold depending
on how many stacks you actually may have
an image but the idea here is that we
were able to be cut because the cells
and the positioning of the cells are in
and out of focus collapsing them
actually helps us project those into
into a plane that's easier for us to see
and for us to analyze so an example of
this is recent data that our colleagues
and in Hamburg de Porres Alexander and
we he used the Inspira gravity trap
ultra low attachment plate and this was
a 96-well format approximately 2500 fg2
cells were seated and they're grown for
five days
they were then challenged with a
mitochondrial and coupler compound
called FC CP overnight an 11-point
dose-response those cells were then
labeled with a tetra methyl methyl
rhodamine ester and for about 45 minutes
and then launched and then these were
imaged on the operetta CLS using a 10x
objective recently used that we had to
use a 10 X 0.3 and a objective is
because the thickness of the particular
plates it we did run it in confocal mode
and also used the environmental control
which was 37 degrees in 5% co2 and
collected a Z stack of approximately
seven planes each being about 10 microns
in size and then a maximum projection
collapsed image was was formed and then
we used the Harmony software for image
analysis so this is an example of some
of the images that were captured from
the 3d spheroids for Pepsi to 3d
spheroids and you can see a DMSO control
and as the intensity when you have high
intensity with tetramethyl rhodamine
that is good functional activity of the
mitochondria but when FC CP which is a
motor control and coupling agent
disrupts the ATP synthesis it will start
to decrease the fluorescence and you can
see that occur as we increase the
concentrations of the sec PD compound
and then that time we get to you
three hundred and a thousand you can see
that they're at three hundred micromolar
there's hardly any visualization of the
cells have basically have broken up the
sphere right has broken up and a
thousand they have disappeared and
likely have washed off washed off the
plate so we're able to take that data
and then and generate a dis response
curve and fit one you know pretty well
for this again these were these were
cells that were challenged just
overnight so from approximately twenty
hours and you can see we have a nice
response there where we can actually
calculate and ic50 curve and this was n
of three different wells so I'm not
going to go back and because the iCub
gave a nice overview and introduction to
the press e scan lists the principles of
it so you know it's a method we know
that we can we can do a pre scan and of
the of cells and then go back and do a
rescan a higher magnification which is
this is a this is a technique that's
really been needed in the community for
a long time and I'm really glad that
Berkman has brought this into their
portfolio it's really easy to use it's
all embedded into the harmony image
analysis workflow it's very flexible so
essentially what we're doing we're going
to there there are two things we have to
do we have to basically create pre-scan
order an algorithm and then we also have
to create a post game or a reskin
algorithm so you're basically you're
you're you're you're Korean these two
different algorithms to do the the
analysis and so this is going to be very
very nice and I'm going to use this
example of the mitotic index
identification using ELA cells HeLa
cells of course many people know or one
of the oldest cell lines available from
a TCC and it's the immortalized ride
from cervical cancer five thousand
approximately five thousand cells are
seated in 3d for while carrier plate and
seated overnight and then they were
challenged with
Nicolle secede and with the
dose-response from point zero zero three
to one point six micromolar for 24 hours
and then the cells were fixed with
caramell dehyde and then labeled with
four different probes so this pros were
anti phosphate histone h3 to measure
mitochondria phalloidin or f-actin and
the related see reporter and then use an
anti tubulin antibody labeled with alexa
fluor 48 and then counter stained with
perks dye three two three four two and
so when we talk about what we're
interested in this particular case of
measuring we're talking about the
mitotic populations here so i'm going to
show you some examples of how we are
able to measure a rare event measurement
of mitotic cell or close to rare event
and i using a 5x objective lens and this
is using it in wide field load and then
we're going to let me switch it over to
do the rescan the different algorithm
using a 63 x water immersion objective
and then taking a small z stack of those
images so this is a just a screen shot
if you will of the harmony you know
image analysis software showing a 5 x
with all four channels so i've shown
here and so that's the first step in the
press e scan method is that we can
identify these cells and that the next
step and we have the whole arsenal of
the harmony image analysis tools to make
evaluations based on the intensity of
the probes are interested in the size
the shape the texture and even dynamics
of these individual objects so now we
can go in and identify these individual
objects shown here using segmentation
routines and then we can next identify a
threshold and the threshold is here is
actually used to identify the positive
cells the cells actually want to go back
and rescan so you can see there's a
the red line that should shown here at
the bottom of the screen as shown here
and that is our measure of our threshold
point and then we're going to actually
identify the cells we want and that's
going to be shown here and here so those
are the positive cells we identified
that are positive for phosphor of
histone h3 so these are the mitotic
cells that are in the overall population
where now we're looking at a sub
population within the context of the the
cells that were in them well that were
challenged with a pulse mean so here's a
screenshot of the DMSO control showing
you the number of objects that were
actually identified and so these are the
these are the scan areas at 63 X so
these are the areas that the system is
going to go back and rescan these
particular areas to identify the mitotic
cells and each one of these boxes and
you can't see itself behind it because
the numbers are overlaying it the
precision on this it's very accurate so
almost every cell if there's only one
cell in there is dead center inside that
new scan area that has been identified
so we increased the concentration of the
compound and you'll see that will will
start to have more and more than not
much change here at low concentrations
of the compound but as we go into higher
concentrations you can see there's many
more so as the cells become arrested
we'll have more cells that that
accumulate into mitosis so once we
identify this we can go back and then
and then rescan as 63 X and rather than
showing you all those images on this a
single shot I wanted to show you some of
the phenotypes that were identified from
this particular this particular plate so
let me start to break down the mitotic
phases we can identify these based on
some phenotype so of course interphase
we're talking about cycling cells here
so these are cells that are g0 g1 s base
and perhaps g2 and then we can identify
cells or in prophase so these are
pasta histone h3 positive cell so that
either these are cells that are mitosis
and early stages of mitosis and they're
identified in the red arrows is shown we
move to there's a couple there's two
Salladhor identified and two metaphase
and so we're now we're starting to look
at basically the the band that goes
across the nucleus as shown shown here
with the orange arrow and then there we
identified two objects appear to be an
interface and and then in telophase and
cytokinesis we were able to identify one
here so we started to have that is this
the splitting of the mitotic spindles
and finally we identified one as you can
see at the bottom screen of the green
arrow there were two identical daughter
cells we start to get that you know the
splitting and division of the cell so
the the the power of this new method of
pressy scan we're able to take a 5x
image and now go back and in the same
well and then in same locations and and
rescan and really get this detailed
information this is the power that's
really been missing in the field this is
a great application to example the show
so as yet convention global image is
another method and I want to talk to you
a little bit more about used in this
particular technology this application
to look at old tissue imaging so really
approaching things that people may be
doing a digital pathology world so we
can actually load up a slide so this
this slide is this older level four
slides its SPS SLES standard format and
this is this an example of the flow
cells that were prepared into showing
you images from using a 20x water
immersion objective or even a 63 explore
emerging objective the quality
that you can actually get using a slide
holder so that the precision of the
stage is very good and actually within
this the magnetic holders of this
actually of the slide holder worked very
well for positioning these slides boards
scan henry scheme so example of this is
a tissue section from a tonsil
so again pre scammed so we can measure
identify where the tonsil actually
resides on the slide so we can we can
use that as shown shown here and you
know here and then we can identify the
tissue regions you're doing a rescan of
the other fields appeals of viewer are
relies of interest so just based on
contrast you can then identify the
tissue itself and then we can basically
stitch these together or have a montage
as a global image but we could also go
back and look at these individual field
and something we call local image so
then we get the quantitative analysis
that we need so that the composite
images there was 353 fields to capture
this particular tissue so it's a lot of
scanning so and went through and I
scanned all of us but we're not
interested in all 353 fields on there
we're only interested in this particular
case of looking at cytokeratin positive
cells so we mask using Carboni software
the region of interest for those and as
you can see at the bottom here on the
that we have identified non epithelial
cells that seem to be a artifact that
was present in this and the tissue
sample which is not uncommon for tissue
preps and we're now we're able to
identify the cytokeratin positive areas
in here so now we're able to just to go
back into those areas and rescan and
look at subpopulations of analysis so
when we go when we do that we're able to
again just look at a small field within
that region we call
again local and this local image we're
able to identify the proteins and the
targets of interests and this is more
telling when we start to look at in this
particular case this tissue was stained
with several different markers beside a
keratin that's cd20 B cells and C D cd4
cells so we can sort of look at the sub
population these logical phenotypes so
again here you can see within within
that's how to care it's impossible so we
can look at start looking at
subpopulations within that layer so
we're talking about several different
layers that we can start those look at
and look at these subpopulations both at
CD twenty years of B cells and then also
looking at cd4 T helper cells and you
can build this list on on looking at
other neurological phenotype
measurements because it really it's
really going to pin on your question and
what you're you're interested in and
looking at this technology this this
approach really opens up a lot of
avenues and doors something I wish I had
several years ago thinking about
inflammation from tumor to tumor
invasion that you have this EMA logical
response that you can start to look at
cytokines chemokines and other
phenotypes other you know seed markers
include HLA you know do you are so I
think it opens up a lot of opportunities
for the community also you have to think
about this is a little bit do this is
look intact tissue really kicked out of
being in context to to the environment
and the only way to do this before
properly was to use flow cytometry so
they'd have to dissociate the tissue and
then run it invite felissa tonic you
then you lose everything in context and
then you can't measure where these
people are phenotypes are in
relationship to a tumor and filtration
for example so I think that there's a
lot of promise here and and it's been
exciting to see how research blossoms
from this technology
or or to seeing that so you know just
really close when and this can mention
some of these other some models that you
could think about used in press e skin a
global image for because really it's a
method for the pre scanning and
rescanning cells tissues or or denials
and other things and the echo sorry
mentioned the scratch NSA and this is an
image from four different fields to show
that this is work I had done when I was
at Duke University with down low and
looking at measuring ex vivo brain slice
imaging so this is you know quite a
large cross-section of a live brain
slice so we can go in and use this type
of method to priest and this and then
rescan higher magnifications and then
with global image we can start to look
at these dendrites and axons that are
going across the particular tissue and
measure that in context rather than have
to break it up into into separate field
so I think that there's a lot there's a
very nice utility and power of having
that another example is work had done in
the past with the pata pack which is a
whole cultural model so this is a micro
pattern of primary human of pata sites
on a model layer of pyroblast cells and
now we can go and identify these
individual islands of pata sites and
make quantitative analysis just on those
very much like the micro tissue approach
and also organelles you think about
organelles and we sell C elegans but
ended up you know could also you know
you look at you know other organelles
systems include flies or even zebrafish
so I think there there's a big promise
of using this scan rescan methodology so
with that I'm going to stop there and I
want to thank you very for your time
thank you Joe before we get started
thank you Joe
before we get started on the question
and answer session I would like to
remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green generate
a button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can our first
question is does PerkinElmer provide any
solution for image storage Thank You
Chrissy that's the question I'd like to
take those echo tests are speaking and
thanks for listening in actually yes we
do obviously there's a little bit of
question on that is that a hardware
related question that case there are a
lot of third-party suppliers for
appropriate hover when it comes to
software we offer our Columbus image
storage and analysis system to take care
of this so the answer is absolutely yes
thank you
next question what is the maximal tissue
thickness that can be analyzed with the
operator
vos okay I think that's the question I
like to answer as well this will depend
to a great extent on the type of tissue
you're analyzing I assume this question
relates to typical 3d spheroids or micro
tissues we've done extensive work on
this type of tissues with different
instruments now and basically two things
are key here one is the water immersion
objectives that really help you to get
deep into the tissue without distorting
the image and the second thing is the
design of the spinning disk the operetta
CLS has a classical spinning disk design
without micro lenses and a pinhole
spacing of about 250 micron and in that
case we typically see a depth of up to
50 60 micron maybe sometimes a little
bit more than that where we can still
successfully sigmund all the nuclei in a
given plane these depths can be improved
upon by clearing the micro tissues if
it's an endpoint si in which case we
typically can double the depths that you
can still analyze or if you have
predominantly need for working with
micro tissues fields are free to use in
Opera Phoenix instead which has a larger
pinhole to pinhole distance which also
translates into a deeper depth of
analysis in these tissues which is
typically also than in the range of
roughly 100 micrometers for a typical
type of tissue if you're interested I
can certainly send some application
notes come on that people publicly thank
you our next question is two parts now
you talked about HCS assays using 3d
models what are the biggest challenges
and imaging and quantifying 3d cell
models and do you have any any advice to
overcome them thanks Christina this is a
giraffe speakin and I'll take that
question on um I first like to say that
at last week's SBI 2 meeting society for
biomolecular image and informatics
meeting in Boston
there was a 3d a colloquial and to
really talk about some of the challenges
with 3d imaging of course does Jakob
pointed out you know light is the main
thing so good light penetration into the
tissue so we can actually detect it you
know it's a challenge and so the it
really comes down to the size of the
spheroids or the tissue that you may be
looking at and what you know how how far
light can penetrate into the tissue and
then be detected it also has to do with
how
measurements are going to be made so as
I mentioned you know in my slides is
that you can collect a series those
deplane images and it collapses into
maximum projection image and that seems
that would be the way most people are
treating 3d image analysis these days
currently although there are some groups
that are actually looking at the
volumetric the voxel space - if they're
actually that the biology warrant is
they're going to need to do that if they
need to look at particular objects in in
three-dimensional space so it really
depends on models now ways to you know
viced overcome these it really comes
down to your asset development so you
need to go through you know that those
those steps of when you develop your
assay and validate it to make sure that
the end of those are reproducible and
there are some groups that have found
that having very large spheroids and in
fact is is not a good thing in fact they
prefer to have smaller spheroids
for the purpose of light penetration but
also for die so getting the dies and
improves into the cells for labeling is
very critical so you can actually detect
those in context of the tissue so I
think it really starts again about you
know Ashley design and development and
validation of the assay Thank You Jo
next question is there an option of
having a color camera or a color filter
on monochrome camera let me take that
one Christy so I'm not 100% clear to
what imaging mode this question relates
so if the question relates to
fluorescence imaging then we obviously
have filters emission filters in place
to adjust the camera settings there and
then filter the emission light when it
comes to bright field imaging in that
case the answer is we do have a single
wavelength of bright field force which
has been selected to really maintain
cells healthy and alive and to minimize
the light exposure of the cell which is
not well suited for colorimetric assays
for
like aging these HIV stains dr. Joseph I
believe you can answer this one as well
can we do white fields and switch to can
focal yes absolutely sir so this is
perfectly possible in their system we we
can offer both those modes in the system
very good
next question for image analysis do you
have different modules to address
different si se translocation cell cycle
granule sa new tryout grow out clothes
etc the answer to this is actually yes
Harmonie software uses an approach to
which we call the building block
approach which label could use it to to
easily assemble specific protocols for
specific assays but it also comes with
preassembled protocols that we call
ready-made solution and they address
common assays exactly like the ones
mentioned here like transportation cell
cycle here at out cruise etc they can be
easily amended as well so it's the the
the standard solution doesn't fit the si
of the customer and the question in hand
they can be easily edited by using the
very same building block approach I
believe we have time for one last
question can you talk about the tools
that the operetta CLS has for phenotypic
screening or phenotype classification
well while I'm at it but it well
continue we have a very broad range of
parameters that we can read off samples
using our hominid software very powerful
is business
specifically for phenotypic
classification are advanced parameters
such as
texture and what we call star morphology
because they have been specifically
designed to answer this type of question
there's a lot of the user to extract
hundreds of features from each cell and
then we use a supervised machine
learning in cut harmony until we call
Fino logic to identify the most the
combination of the most relevant
parameters to tell different phenotypes
apart is that is not sufficient for the
question at hand we can transfer data to
another tool which we call high content
profiler it's based on Spotfire which
also enables completely unsupervised
machine learning to do feature reduction
and multiplayer ability analysis I would
one I would like to once again thank dr.
Jacob tester and jump in mr. Joe Trask
for their presentation I would also like
to thank our sponsor PerkinElmer for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
March 8 2017 you will receive an email
from laberd's alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events we hope to see you
next time goodbye